A few months back, my brother Ian showed me an
amusing tumblr post. A link is in the description
if you want to read the whole thing, but long
story short, this post lays out a format called
Oulipo Dragon Scotsman. In ODS, participants play
with a 99-card card singleton deck that is led by
a Commissar, a legendary creature which can be
cast at any time. Okay, it’s EDH, but without
any Es in the names of cards. Naturally I had to
do something with this information, which brings
us to today. Last week I instructed the people of
my discord server to submit a deck with no Es, and
to also include an approximately 100 word written
work to accompany it, also without Es. Was that
part because getting almost 400 submissions on my
last deckbuilding challenge just about killed me?
A snail never tells. However, among the much more
manageable 180 submissions that these somewhat
irritating requirements produced were some really
delightful submissions, and in this video I want
to tell you about some of them and how they
managed the daunting task of excluding the most
common character in the English Alphabet. I’ll
also be including a number of honorable mentions
on my website, since there were really great
submissions, both in decks and writing quality.
A major struggle with this challenge was finding
decks and archetypes that aren’t too hindered by a
lack of Es. Not being able to build decks with
Es eliminates roughly 83% of all magic cards,
so if you have 6 cards that do a particular thing,
on average all but one of them will be eliminated.
However, some types of cards had shockingly
few of their options eliminated. For one,
Polymorph cards—only around half of
all polymorph cards were eliminated,
leaving a respectable five left for any red blue
decks to enjoy, which was taken advantage of
by a neat Yasova deck that was submitted.
Another survivor was the card Rat Colony,
which allowed people to easily fill out a large
portion of their deck, and this was utilized by
a particular Jarad deck. A third deck that was
relatively unhindered was Ratadrabik Nazgul combo,
a deck style submitted by several people. The
one I’m going to be highlighting here is a
delightfully 2000s deck—Nell’s Arcum Dagsson
station deck. Let’s start with the poem:
[Reading text on screen]
Arcum Dagsson is a spicy commander from Coldsnap,
and he’s one that has the potential to be quite
powerful in modern day unrestricted EDH. Four
mana for a creature that can sacrifice an
artifact creature to find a nonartifact creature
every turn is quite potent, and the noncreature
artifacts we have available to search for in
the year of our lord 2025 are quite horrifying
compared to what existed back when Arcum Dagsson
was printed in 2006. However, what do the top tier
tutoring targets like Darksteel Forge, Portal
to Phyrexia, and God-Pharaoh’s Statue all have
in common? Es of course. So naturally any Arcum
Dagsson enjoyers had to get a bit more creative,
which brings me to the tutoring targets of
choice for this deck—Stations. There were
four cards printed in Fifth Dawn with “station”
in the name, and it just so happens that none of
them have Es. Two of them you may know as
classic combo pieces—Blasting Station and
Grinding Station—whereas Summoning Station and
Salvaging Station are somewhat less popular cards
that only hipster youtubers play. However, when
the four of these are in play at the same time,
all of their respective abilities and untap
clauses merge together to form an infinite combo
with each other, so long as a low-cost artifact
for Salvaging Station is in the graveyard.
The two high cost stations are activated to create
permanents which untaps the low-cost stations,
and then those two are activated to sacrifice the
permanents and inflict harm on opponents which
untaps the high cost stations, rinse
and repeat until opponents are dead.
So the heart of this deck is these four artifacts
and a commander who can find them, but what
supports that? Well first, artifact creatures.
This is the resource that Arcum needs to create
his stations, so naturally there are 19 of them.
These cards span a variety of purposes, with the
most common being helping the deck ramp. Some of
them are a bit filler, but with a commander like
Arcum Dagsson that’s not really a problem. The
other key thing this deck has is protection—Arcum
is a scary commander, so to keep him alive this
deck is packing nine counterspells and five other
pieces of protection. Filling out the rest of this
deck is a handful of removal spells, as well as a
variety of other artifact-related cards. There are
a handful of cards that seem here specifically to
synergize with certain stations—a number of
1 cost noncreature artifacts allow Salvaging
Station to come online, and there are likewise
a couple cards that can let artifacts untap.
Trading Post also lightly synergizes with a couple
different stations, yet another possible machine
that can be cobbled together. All of this has
a very retro energy about it, and I enjoy that.
Moving along, something else you may note
about this no Es format is that it excludes
a basic land—forests. This challenge did have a
somewhat-below-average number of green-containing
decks in general, but there were a surprising
number of people who opted to build a mono green
deck. There are something like 11 lands without
Es that both produce green and are legal in a
mono green commander deck, and pairing those with
a modest number of green-producing mana rocks can
get you up to a symbol count that’s an aggressive
mulligan policy away from being adequate. Adding
on an extra color makes the situation a surprising
amount better—it seems like nonbasic lands tend to
have fewer Es than other card types, so there are
a surprising number of options within two color
decks. That brings me to a green deck I want to
highlight—Shuckle’s Momir Vig biovisionary deck.
There was actually another Momir Vig biovisionary
deck, shout out to the person who made that one,
but this is the one I’m opting to
feature. Let’s start with the story.
[Reading text on screen]
That story laid out a lot of what the deck is
doing, but let’s do a brief rundown. Momir Vig
is a commander with two abilities attached—casting
green creature spells lets you tutor up creatures
to the top of your library, and casting
blue creature spells lets you draw the
top card of your library. So, casting blue green
spells puts the cards directly into your hand,
in classic original Ravnica fashion. Biovisionary
is a card that wins you the game if you have at
least four copies of it in play on your endstep.
In a singleton format like EDH, this means that
some form of copying is generally required to
actually make it work as a wincon, and naturally
this deck has a fair amount of that. 12 cards
exist to copy it in some form or other, though
these span a wide range of things—you’ve got the
basic copy plan which will take a bit of effort,
you’ve got the stronger though non-tutorable
plan of using a card like Sakashima’s Will on
a wide board, and you’ve got riskier plans such
as exiling Biovisionary under Soul Foundry and
hoping to be able to activate it four times.
As for finding each of these components,
the deck features nine Simic creatures for
purposes of tutoring up clones, as well as
a number of other green creatures. There are
also cards like Crystal Shard and Umbilicus,
which bounce creatures to be re-cast and can
also let the deck repeat ETBs on top of that.
Outside of that, this deck features a good
amount of ramp, which seems like a good idea
for a couple reasons. For one, Momir Vig is a
five mana commander with a concerning effect,
so that’s basically a seven or nine mana commander
if you think about it. Outside of commander tax,
Momir Vig also feeds the deck card advantage at a
healthy clip, so naturally it makes sense to make
sure to have a way of spending that. In terms of
green symbols, this deck contains 15 amongst its
lands and two amongst its colorless ramp for
a grand total of 17 symbols, which certainly
isn’t great but can be made workable enough with
a somewhat aggressive mulligan policy. This deck
certainly represents a fun navigation
of this challenge’s tricky requirement.
A number of people went for more conceptual decks.
No Es is a very specific format requirement,
and asking for some sort of writing submission
likewise put people into a creative zone. One cool
choice was a K’rrik deck, with the deckbuilder
pointing out that K’rrik was canonically
originally named Kerrick, and his choice to
remove the E from his name meshes nicely with
the nature of this challenge. Another fun choice
was an Asmorano mardica daistina culdacar deck
that features an Underworld Cookbook in a
rule-0ed sideboard and a Wish in the mainboard,
with the idea being that Asmorano mardica daistina
culdacar lost her cookbook and is wishing for its
return. There were also not one, not two, but
three X decks submitted—that’s the Unstable card
that puts itself into your opponent’s hand.
The deck I’ll be highlighting is an Iron Man
deck that also chooses to engage in just a bit of
silver border action. Let’s start with the story.
[Reading text on screen]
Iron Man himself is a 5 mana flying beater
who creates treasures and offers a birthing
pod sort of effect for artifacts each turn.
Should I refer to that sort of effect as an
Oswald Effect? A repurposing effect? Anyway, turns
artifacts into other artifacts. The silver border
card this deck features is Now I Know My ABCs, a
card that wins you the game on your upkeep if you
control permanents with all 26 letters of the
alphabet in the name. Iron is actually a great
choice to go with this for a couple reasons.
For one, treasures! That’s an E! Secondly,
it allows the deck to go hunting for some
of the less common letters out there that
might be attached to artifacts. Naturally, this
deck has a number of artifacts with less common
characters—Tamiyo’s Journal, Blazing Torch,
Jhoira’s Familiar, Acquisition Octopus, and so
on. There’s even Spy Kit, an equipment that gives
a creature the names of all legendary creatures,
which certainly simplifies the gameplan a bit
as long as you can keep the creature in play
until your upkeep. Even outside the artifacts
there’s a lot of variety—we’re got Qumulox here
for that lovely french vanilla Mirrodin
gameplay, as well as Grazilaxx and Xorn.
The core of the deck is Now I Know My ABCs, but
this deck has a good number of options to pivot
into more of a conventional artifact beatdown
sort of plan if needed. Sharding Sphinx and a
handful of other flyers make for a solid plan
alongside combat damage to player effects.
All of this and more is explained
in the deck’s 700 word primer,
also including no Es. I have to respect the
effort on display here—I briefly toyed with
the idea of writing this script E-less,
but quickly abandoned that idea when it
became clear how difficult long form writing
without Es is, particularly when it comes to
navigating around common words I might
normally use like commander or deck.
So far I’ve chosen to feature decks that have a
neat premise or which flaunt restrictions in some
sort of creative way. However, the final deck
I’m going to show off in this video is one with
a decidedly more focused goal—Mirrorwing’s Tiamat
deck. I’ll let the description explain the basics.
[Reading text on screen]
You know, it’s occurring to me that all four decks
I’m showcasing feature a commander that tutors for
tools that help with some sort of unusual combo.
You should definitely blame 3/3 Elk for that,
he helped me in selecting the top decks here.
Anyway, let’s talk about the commander—Tiamat
is a five color dragon that costs seven
mana and tutors for five dragons. You
might think this means that this deck is a
dragon deck, and it does have two dragons,
but that’s where it decides to call it good.
This is because in the context of this deck,
Tiamat’s role is simple—he’s just the way the deck
turns infinite mana into a win. I say infinite
mana because this is a food chain combo deck. Food
chain is a card that allows a player to exile a
creature to add its mana value plus one in mana
that can only be spent on creatures. This combos
with Misthollow Griffin, a four mana creature
that can be cast from exile, creating infinite
mana that can be spent on creature spells. Once
infinite mana is obtained, Tiamat is then cast,
searching for Dragonlord Dromoka and Hoarding
Broodlord. Dromoka is here for protection for the
rest of the combo, shutting off opposing spells
and thereby protecting the two critical creatures
that will follow from creature removal. Hoarding
Broodlord is a dragon that gives all a player’s
spells cast from exile convoke, and on ETB tutors
up a card to exile that can be cast. That card is
most likely to be Joyful Stormsculptor, a card
that deals 1 damage to each opponent whenever
a convoke spell is cast. Once each of these
is on the field, the deck then goes back to
loop Misthollow Griffin with Food Chain a bunch
more times, since it now has convoke when being
cast from exile and thus deals 1 damage to each
opponent per cast, eventually burning them down.
Because Food Chain exiles as a the cost on the
ability and because the deck plays Dromoka before
the other critical creatures, almost all creature
removal actually can’t interact with this combo,
which is pretty wild. The two things that can
interact with it are enchantment removal to
destroy Food Chain and counterspells to
nail key spells, and the deck naturally
runs 8 counterspells to deal with that. It also
runs 9 cards to slow down opposing gameplans,
which makes sense to buy just a little bit of
time for the deck to set up. Outside of this,
the rest of the deck’s cards focus on pushing
it to the point at which it can combo off—we’ve
got effectively 35 lands, 14 sources of mana
acceleration, 11 tutors, and 13 draw spells
to let the deck find and play Misthollow Griffin
and Food Chain. A secondary benefit of Tiamat is
that the deck has ample options for what to use
for these—while losing Es restricts the cardpool
a lot, having five colors allows basically
all of these to still be respectable choices.
It also allows the deck to have less trouble with
manabase than it might otherwise—a full 8 original
dual lands don’t contain E, and though there are
only two untapped fetches available, another four
tapped fetches make this a bit less problematic.
Overall, this is a very fun deck to showcase the
limits of the no-E format, though I’d probably
add another dragon or two as a backup plan.
So those were the decks I wanted to highlight, but
I’ll briefly mention a handful more that will be
in the honorable mentions. Pillowlake submitted
a sort of build-your-own-slicer deck—it’s
a Godo deck that wants to find Assault Suit,
and they included a very flavorful story to
go with it. AllusivePanda submitted a Gonti,
Canny Acquisitor theft deck that includes no
green symbols whatsoever, and which needs to use
one of its other theft cards to steal a source of
green mana from an opponent as a result. Finally,
Salmon submitted a high power Glarb Doomsday deck
that’s pretty cool. There were actually several
doomsday decks submitted. You can check out all
those decks at the link to my website down in
the description. Hopefully you enjoyed seeing
these decks, and if you hated every second of
it you can move along with your day in peace
knowing that this is the last one of these
I’ll be doing for at least a few months.
With that said, thanks for watching! And thanks
to Archidekt for supporting the channel. One of
my favorite things about the site is the
front and center scryfall-style search box
that can allow quick and effortless filtering
of cards by oracle text, color, or mana value.
A link to all my decks is in the description
if you want to check them out and see how many
times the word “attack” or “search” shows up
in them. I’d also like to thank my patrons,
some of whom are onscreen now. It’s always great
to know I can make what I want and am somewhat
shielded from the whims of the algorithm
by the kind people who directly support me.
If you want to support the channel, a
link to my patreon is in the description.